big girl
cardi b and offset's three-year-old
daughter culture is living her best life
at the trampoline park
oh yes honey on monday the [ __ ] rapper
and her hubby bundled up for a sweet
family outing ready to go out
say daddy hurry up
and once dad was ready to roll it was
nothing but fun at the indoor park
complete with a foam pit
ready to jump now
you ready to jump
yeah
lots and lots of yummy snacks
you want to eat some popcorn yeah
yeah
and the whole adventure totally wore out
little culture
later that night the grammy winner
shared this clip of her firstborn
catching some z's alongside the caption
she is so perfect
she's so cute i love her
but culture she's a girl who can do both
before the fam hit the trampoline park
cardi shared this adorable video of her
little girl posing in front of three
large christmas trees during their
family holiday photo shoot
look at the camera nice there you go
[Music]
okay there we go
and culture she's already a natural in
front of the camera just like her famous
mama oh snappity snap snap cardi even
captioned the video quote so much like
me
beautiful you know put your hands on
yours like that again
nice
the mom of two also shared this sweet
pick of culture with her sister khalia
offset's daughter from a previous
relationship the girls served up a look
in matching red dresses complete with
hair bows
giving fashion yes
[ __ ] and if all that wasn't sweet enough
cardi also gave a rare glimpse of her
and offset's newborn son while showing
off their over-the-top christmas decor
this year we went with what officer
suggested he wanted a nice christmas
vibe
ready
okay
the grammy winner first gave fans a look
at their little bundle of joy whose name
they have yet to reveal back in
september
[Music]
so it's pretty obvious cardi and offset
they're all about family back in 2018
cardi gushed to e.t about her man's
parenting skills he already has three
kids so i already fell in love uh the
way that he was a dad already i'm like
oh my god i can have a little one with
this guy he's really good he's really
good and the following year she told et
how much she loves being a mom
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile and everything
[Music]